[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mon bon public de limoges j'ai
une question pour vous ce soir et elle
est importante
vous êtes plutôt star wars ou star trek
ah ok ok bon là on est dans les
vaisseaux spatiaux le space opera
ok ok si vous devez donner une image
d'un bon mentor plutôt gandalf ou plutôt
dumbledore
on est dans l'heroic fantasy on est un
peu dans tout ça et vous noterez quand
je vous pose ces questions je ne vous
demande même pas est ce que vous êtes
geek ou pas je parle déjà du principe
que vous l'êtes un petit peu
alors que vous l'avez peut-être pas déjà
revendiqué on est noyé dans cette
culture geek vous avez vu les films qui
sortent en ce moment on est noyé de
super héros francis le cercle merci
merci ca ce type d'image ça peu vexé si
comme unité si communauté de geeks en
même temps je vous laisserai déchiffrer
un ça peut faire des débats enflammés en
famille ou avec les amis alors qu'on
parle ni religion ni politique vous
imaginez le sujet geek culture ou
religion vous avez quatre heures on est
exactement là dedans et c'est une
économie énorme des budgets monumentaux
alors des gens ont essayé de définir
c'est quoi un geek et ils ont essayé de
donner une définition ils ont réfléchi
c'est quand même fou d'essayer de
définir et de mettre dans des cases des
gens qui par définition on essaye de ne
pas être dans une case
mais on en est là alors du coup on va
pas forcément s'attarder sur la
définition du geek mais on peut
s'intéresser un peu plus à un certain
état d'esprit
mais quand même des choses qui ressorte
la passion le geek va plus loin qu'un
fan
il est passionné par son sujet quels
qu'ils soient et souvent on va dire oui
c'est lié à l'informatique ces deux
nouvelles technologies en même temps de
nos jours tout est un peu lié à
l'informatique nouvelles technologies
donc c'est quand même réducteur
personnellement je connais un grand fan
débit
'les je connais tout où il a des
exclusivités il a les vinyles ils
achètent tout il connaît toutes les
anecdotes
c'est une forme de geek ça ne choque pas
alors on va s'intéresser un peu cette
culture et on va faire un peu d'histoire
ensemble on va parler des super héros
le premier super héros qui a vraiment
été super héros comme on l'entend c'est
superman 1938
première parution de superman on est aux
états unis on est à la veille de la
seconde guerre mondiale et il faut créer
des champions et ça va vite s'enchaîner
39 batman 40 flash green lantern 41
wonder woman c'est rigolo c'est tous les
films qui sont en train de sortir
aujourd'hui et qui vont sortir encore ok
donc on est un peu dans la dans la fuite
par l'imaginaire pour se créer des
champions et on se rend compte que
l'imaginaire ça marche bien alors on va
aller plus loin on va aller plus loin et
on va créer des univers entier mais il
pourra se plonger dedans 1934 le hobbit
1951 le seigneur des anneaux et là on
commence à toucher des communautés très
très très très très fans qui sont à même
de vous faire des débats incroyable sur
un point de détail dans le livre qui
pourrait refaire des complots des
terreaux théorie et c'est ok ça ça
marche bien 51
isaac asimov fondation on mélange un
univers entier dans lequel on peut se
plonger et le space opera
on est dans la conquête spatiale on
conquiert les galaxies alors là c'est là
on enchaîne on enchaîne star trek on
enchaîne star wars 77
donc là on a des communautés de gens qui
sont passionnés qui se retrouvent et
qu'ils veulent aller toujours plus
immersif ils veulent interagir avec cet
univers années soixante dix années 80
les jeux de rôles 70 donjons et dragons
on continue on a les jeux de cartes à
jouer
magic 93 je me trait de côte et pokémon
mai
on en est là quand même on en est là un
univers imaginaire et on interagit avec
lui l'an commence à toucher la période
des mangas 80 90 on l'a connu en france
180 8 grâce à club dorothée des disputes
mémorable avec ma mère parce qu'il
fallait que je termine mon épisode de
dragon ball z avant d'aller à l'école
bien sûr les chevaliers du zodiaque
nicky larson et là il va se produire une
bascule on se dit ouais il ya une
culture sougeal sous jacentes
il ya la bd franco-belge et les dc
comics et puis il ya des mangas
oui mais 99 matrix au delà du film avec
la trilogie avec tout son sens profond
on franchit quelque chose c'est que
c'est un film très très très orienté
pour les geeks le protagoniste est un
développeur informatique qui sort pas
beaucoup qui est persuadé qu'il existe
un monde imaginaire au fur et à mesure
de la trilogie lille se transforme en
héros il se trouve que le monde
imaginaire est en fait le monde réel qui
a été créée par les robots il gagne le
coeur de la fille et il sauve le monde
pas mal ses propres 2001 2001 c'est pas
mal c'est le seigneur des anneaux et là
il va se produire quelque chose d'assez
intéressant parce que seigneur des
anneaux il ya toute une nouvelle
communauté geek qui arrive qui
s'intéressent à cet univers qui n'avait
jamais lu les bouquins et il arrive se
disent ouais c'est génial sénat fait
tout ben oui mais non parlant à ton père
parle d'en hâter son oncle et tante
ils l'ont peut-être lui il ya déjà 50
ans art et là on touche un côté culturel
parce que ça devient inter
générationnelle et on a deux les changes
à table à table repas de famille on peut
échanger c'est sympa or vous l'aurez
compris moi je suis arrivé un petit peu
dans cette période un dragon ball dans
l'adolescence ces jeux de cartes à jouer
magic étonnamment ça me faisait
rencontré pas mal de monde
j'ai beaucoup sympathisé et après les
jeux en réseau je viens pc assez tard 16
ans
quelques facilités je me retrouve dans
des équipes j'ai eu l'occasion de faire
pas mal de national pas mal
d'international et j'en ai vécu quelques
années je vais même pas m'attarder
dessus
m'a apporté des choses fantastiques
beaucoup de relations l'esprit de
compétition l'esprit l'équipe et une
grande combativité
parce que quand vous vous adressez à une
communauté de geeks et que vous êtes sur
le devant de la scène
les retours sont violents en bien comme
en mal il faut s'accrocher et derrière
étonnamment sam a même servi en tant que
chef d'entreprise
déjà parce que je vais plutôt monté la
boîte comme un chef d'equipe avec ma
femme donc capitaine d'équipé tous dans
le même bateau on y va et je passais les
entretiens d'embauché ou jetés sur la
dernière ligne du cv tu fais des jeux
vidéo raconte moi tu fais quoi parce que
là on touche du coup à l'imaginaire de
la personne c'est bien pour y déterminer
un profil hormis ses compétences
techniques brutes des coups ratés plutôt
soutien tu es plutôt attaquants
défenseurs tu es plutôt stratège et
organise les choses c'est sympa ça veut
dire que cette personne en face de moi
sur son temps libre
aime bien faire ça c'est ce qui l'est
c'est ce qu'il souhaite devenir
c'est assez intéressant alors quand on
fait le tour un petit peu de tout ça et
bien on a gagné
vous en doutiez on était une culture
sous jacente est maintenant on est une
culture dominante
nous avons gagné si vous avez un doute
l'industrie du jeu pèse plus lourd que
l'industrie du cinéma et de la musique
réunit c'est une économie
incroyable les dernières compétitions
mondiales remplissent le stade de séoul
60000 personnes pendant trois jours
non-stop pour diffuser en 18 langues
avec des commentateurs professionnels 8
millions de prix pour les gagnants
les deux millions de personnes qui
regardent les matchs en direct c'est pas
pire que l'économie du football et donc
on a gagné mais on a un problème on
n'était pas prêt vous le souhaitez pas
forcément c'était notre identité d'être
geek on était en vert et contre tous
il ya 15 ans être geek c'était quelque
chose il fallait l'affirmé il fallait
subir la pression familiale alf allait
se dire mais c'est pas comme ça que tu
trouveras un boulot fait des études
arrête de jouer aussi tard le soir
comme quoi ça mène à tout mais ça crée
quand même s'intéresser à la culture
geek quelle qu'elle soit il fallait lire
beaucoup fallait se renseigner beaucoup
fallait communiquer beaucoup maintenant
nos jours la culture geek est quand même
servi sur un plateau
elle est à portée de clic de page
wikipédia et d'aller un petit peu au
cinéma
alors on est très fiers moi je suis très
fier de pouvoir échanger que les enfants
que mes amis beaucoup plus librement
mais en même temps il ya quelque chose
qui a été perdu ce qui a été perdu et
c'est cette combativité ce qui a été
perdu
c'était ce côté un petit peu en vert et
contre tous sans dire qu'on est des
marginaux normalement le geek à cette
culture du pourquoi pas parce qu'il est
contre l'autorité mais parce qu'il va
constamment posé la question mais
pourquoi c'est ainsi parce qu'il cherche
l'explication et c'est perçu comme un
côté un peu marginal ce pas le cas on a
perdu ça c'est dommage on a quand même
des emblèmes de glee qu'un de nos jours
dans le monde qui change le monde pense
à bill gates microsoft
mark zuckerberg facebook et nous jours
elon muscles un bon champion tesla space
x
donc ces gens là à l'heure actuelle ils
changent le monde
alors moi je pense qu'on va arriver à
une saturation on est inondé de la
culture geek les blockbusters sur les
super-héros il en a déjà vingt deux
programmés jusqu'en 2022 et huit autres
en suspens selon s'il ya du succès ou
pas on va faire une overdose
donc du coup cette culture geek que l'on
a porté fièrement est en train de faire
petit à petit une overdose et je pense
qu'en 2025
eh bien on sera à plus une culture on
sera une mode c'était la mode et elle a
passé
je suis un geek 10 à 15 ans je me
reconnais pas forcément dans les digues
de maintenant même si j'ai rien contre
je pense que je me retrouverais dans les
geeks dans 15 ans on a commencé à
changer le monde
certains continuent de le faire on
continuera de le faire dans 15 ans je
sais pas ce que va devenir le monde dans
15 ou 20 ans on va continuer de le
changer et un jour peut-être qu'on le
sauvera
[Applaudissements]